foreign
[Music]
my name's Mo and I'm 15. my name is Kyle
when I'm 18 years old
[Music]
I thought it was a good opportunity to
get my opinion of a local area I heard
get my voice heard see what things
they're planning on doing and see how I
can get involved
[Music]
being like such a diversity of opinions
and
like we're not all just knowing we're
not all the same I think it's the idea
of that we all want to do something and
sort of when you've got a group of
people that all want to do something
together it really does encourage you
and makes you think right if I can do it
if they feel that they can do it we can
all do it I was really nervous when I
started doing it but as I've started
doing it more
I feel more confidence yeah that sort of
voice like I'd use more and yeah I was
kind of getting off really I just I
really enjoyed people like things are
changing and that's why I keep coming
back
[Music]
give it 10 years we will then be the
ones up front dealing with this so
as much as everyone's voices are all
important young people in particular
because we are going to inherit it so
it's good to have a voice for young
people directly so they can say what
they want to say without you know people
assuming what they think and just go
along with it
our safe spaces one of the main things
we're working with our safe spaces and
find it another safety buildings I think
it's quite I think it's a great thing
if something you're interested in I say
go for it it's honestly so worth it if
you want the chance to make change do it
and this is a place that can help get it
done sort of thing problem with
complaining is that unless you actually
do something yourself and nothing's
actually going to get done so
better to be proactive